Chris waters here with another gamespot
news update another sony developer has
jumped ship uncharted director Justin
Richmond has announced he's leaving his
position at Naughty Dog to go work for
League of Legends developer riot games
sony confirmed the departure in a
statement to gamespot but also added
that development of the next uncharted
will not be affected in the letter to
IGN Richmond wrote I have in fact made
the decision to leave Naughty Dog I love
the company and the people and know that
they will continue to create awesome
games going forward on a happier note
after careful consideration and
exploration I have joined Riot Games
there are some really innovative stuff
going on here that I can't wait to be a
part of Naughty Dog recently made
headlines due to the departure of lead
writer Amy Hennig while original reports
stated that henig was forced out of the
company by the Last of Us creative
director of Neil druckmann and Bruce
Straley Naughty Dog clarified in a later
statement that the two were not involved
in what transpired we've reached out to
Sony and naughty dog for further
clarification on Richmond's departure
we'll be sure to keep you updated right
here on gamespot com